>>Boy: A Rube Goldberg machine
is complicated for a simple task.
>>Girl: Boss Level is a week
where we work with our home base
to complete a project
by the end of the week.
And we also don't have homework
or any other of our usual classes.
>>Teacher: You walk into
a Boss Level classroom,
you're not seeing really a classroom.
All of the desks and
tables are pushed aside.
You're seeing a lot of
materials of all different sorts
that are kind of strewn around.
You see a lot of sixth
graders either tinkering
or in a group brainstorming,
possibly sketching.
It's a lot of creativity and
innovation going on in the space.
>>Boy: We could do something
like this, if we had like a hold.
>>Boy: How about this one?
>>Girl: They're tiny.
>>Boy: No, we already have a marble.
Yeah, I fixed them here.
>>Boy: Wait, wait, wait, wait.
To make it look cool.
>>Teacher: My favorite part
about Boss Level is the
actual building phase.
When kids fail during the creation of
Rube Goldberg and then they iterate,
they are really learning
to take risks.
>>Girl: Failure is really bad, but
I guess if you have a good attitude,
then you can always make
it what you wanted it to be
and not to get frustrated.
So failure's not so bad
if you know how to fix it.
>>Boy: Failure reframed as iteration
means when you fail, just try again.
>>Kids: Yeeeahhh!!!
>>What?! What, what,
NO, Nooooo!
>>Teacher: Students really
take a lot of ownership
for the machines that they create.
Their advisor is in the room, but
their advisor really is not helping
to do any of the building,
or even creating.
They're really just there as an adult
to help facilitate and to make sure
that things are going
smoothly and safely.
So if you walk into a
Boss Level classroom,
you really see the students as
teachers, as learners, as innovators,
and they are really helping each
other through the iteration process.
They are creating this blueprint
for their machine in the beginning.
They're putting it to the test,
they're watching it, they're seeing
where the kinks are, where they
need to iterate and they are going
through this process
really on their own.
I think that's also a really
great thing about the process,
to be able to watch students move
through this system on their own
and actually succeed at it.
>>Girl: Home base is...
I think it might be a
little bit like a homeroom.
>>Teacher: To be able to see
students really incorporate things
that they learn in
home base and model
that during the building
is really a great process.
One of my home base students,
who's in eighth grade now,
talks all the time about how he feels
that Rube Goldberg was what really
brought us together as a home base.
So it's a really great moment for us.
>>Boy: Since you have to work
together and you spend a lot
of time together in a classroom or in
a confined space, that you really get
to know one another and
how one another works.
>>Boy: If you're doing
a Rube Goldberg machine,
you need to have a lot of teamwork
so that one person isn't just working
on the front and like a million
people are working on the middle.
You need to have an even
share of everything.
>>Teacher: Having gone through
the Rube Goldberg process
with my own home base,
it really proved
to be beneficial for many reasons.
I mean, not only are
they implementing skills
that they've learned in the
classroom, but as a home base,
you really see them
bond and really build.
You know, they're really kind of
stuck in a room for days at a time
and they have to really
learn how to get along,
how to share ideas,
how to respect ideas.
Teamwork is probably
the most important facet
of Rube Goldberg building.
>>Girl: If one person makes
one part of the machine
and another person makes
another part of the machine,
if they don't work together, those
parts won't work together either
and it probably will
not complete its goal.